never Trump never Hillary I can't
support Hillary Clinton after the way
these elections have gone I would've
never been for Hillary and I will never
be for Hillary I won't vote for her I
would have a very very hard time coming
up with a Clinton vote I tried for the
whole year to convince myself if the
polls come down to with them neck and
neck
on Election Day and and I've exhausted
every other option I could possibly go
and and none of the third-party
candidates impress me I'll hold my
breath and I'll vote for it
Pam Alexis Garcia with reason TV we're
here at the Democratic National
Convention in Philadelphia the City of
Brotherly Love but there are a lot of
Democrats who aren't really feeling the
embrace to the party and we're right
here at City Hall just right down the
street from the Philadelphia Convention
Center at the March for Bernie Sanders
rally to find out what Sanders
supporters think and what they plan on
doing next what was it about Bernie that
attracted you to him I think for me it
was the collusion of money in politics I
think that corporate greed is really the
issue that we're I'm most concerned
about I love that he's calling the truth
out about the way our political system
works Medicare for all no TPP do you
think Hillary Clinton represents any of
those ideals that you like we're not
absolutely not kill it Hillary Clinton
represents the almighty dollar Clinton
and the elites in the DNC are not
interested in that equity for all of
America and they're not interested in
taking advantage of this moment they're
interested only in skating by and
retaining power Clinton needs to earn
Sanders delegates votes and so far she
has not done that we saw a couple days
ago at the DNC email League what was
your reaction to that outrage complete
outrage it was not a surprise but it was
just confirmation of everything we kind
of thought the DNC has consistently been
working against Bernie so I'm not
surprised now we have proved that they
were making fun of him that they were
tanking his campaign on purpose they
have been completely unfair to our
candidate and we feel no obligation to
vote for them now
firsthand how the system is rigged
against our citizens just like it was
rigged against Bernie Sanders he never
had a chance
Donald Trump came out and made a play
for Bernie supporters would you ever no
no absolutely not Donald Trump is a joke
a Donald Trump is a racist
he's a bigoted person Trump is a liar
for sure but also a naked fascist and
racist seeing with this election how
unpopular Hillary and Trump are do you
think that there is a future for a third
party option absolutely I would love to
see I would love to see at least Gary
Johnson get into the debates and Jill
Stein would you ever consider a third
party I think about that I haven't made
up my mind I've been a Democrat for 20
years I've never voted to party before
so this will be the first election that
I vote third party but my party left me
behind
they're obviously deciding that they
don't want us on their side so fine then
we'll walk I would definitely look to
third party and and and ironically you
know think people think it's a dangerous
time for that I think it's potentially
an opportunity for that if Stein for
example can get into the debate she has
a footing to carry on the Sanders
message I plan to vote for Jill Stein in
that election
I lean most towards Jill Stein if I vote
for anyone at all because the Jill Stein
platform is the one that is simply the
one most morally acceptable to me in
November I can't help but notice because
your sign looks familiar it's a the Ron
Paul that kind of logo were you a Paul
supporter
no I would say libertarianism and the
Paul's is not the direction that would
benefit most people in the country
equitably that we've seen Gary Johnson
he's actually polling pretty close to
getting into the debate it he became a
viable option with that choice be at all
interesting to you or would it be like a
lesser of three people know if David
Duke polled enough to get onto the
debate stage I wouldn't really look at
him as the lesser of three evils Gary
Johnson as far as I know also espouses
horrible things that would serve America
not morally correctly between Trump
Clinton and Johnson would he be an
option
he would be although I don't support
libertarian policies but I think he's
actually better than either one of them
I think the guy is a good guy I like his
social issues stances I don't think I
can support a libertarian candidate over
Hillary or Trump absolutely I have some
libertarian tendencies for sure I think
I'm you know gonna explore every option
before I would even consider exploring
Hillary as you know somebody I would
ever vote for